we are continuing with graphing all
starts nothing's impossible feel about
that summers when looking at graphing
and the technique that we're going to
introduce today kind of was opened the
door on all the kinds of things that
make a graph I've driven of all these
families of drafts that we had a look at
before um polynomials expenditures of
longest shoot craps etc etc right we've
kind of treated them as like a different
separate Wells right it's like this is
meant to be a cubic or a parabola and it
doesn't mix with other stuff okay
an addition and subtraction ordinance is
the simplest way that you can mix
together two things that are meant to be
quite different so just have a look at
video exerci not giving you and even
just the first one so let's do one a to
go this is a fairly easy water okay what
you're gonna need for this is now
obviously unitive set axes it will also
be helpful if you have at least more
than one color for five the graphs that
we're going to draw if you only have one
color i will show you the way on this
first graph that i will overcome that
but it's it's a lot easier if you've got
to come so it says usually the process
of the digital subtraction of ordinance
so the right way you're like what's an
order okay now what would you guess and
order the is based on like what you've
seen this one before yeah okay so
usually we say for X's and Y's we call
them coordinates right order the
coordinates I just like another one for
the words of these four values okay now
these a bit of terminology you that's
worth learning for you even though
they're called
coordinates right um one of these is the
monitor and one of them is not and they
have special names so the ordinate is
the sky this is the order the x value
has a weird name that no one has ever
heard of and that no one ever really
uses and it's called the sister know
what's written that come from yet oddly
anyone talks about it and you'll see why
when we start graphing this thing it's
all about the autumn
that's that's the important thing so to
begin with the graph we're looking at is
y equals x plus the absolute value of x
I believe is that correct yep okay so
what I want to think about in terms of
this graph is of the components on this
graph okay they're up to there's the X
and there's the absolute value of X
independently I know what each of those
looks like so this first graph I'm going
to show you what if you only have one
color and in the exam maybe you're like
oh I want to play it safe I only want to
do it in black so this is how I would do
it I'm going to take each of these
individual graphs and I'm going to put
them on my Cartesian plane and I'm gonna
like dot or - them in some way so that I
show these are not even originally the
real graph they're just the bits that it
got to go together okay so let's do the
easy one first he is X 1 cos s okay we
know what that looks like and what I
want to include in addition to that
literally it is [ __ ] - that is well what
does the absolute value of x look like
how's it different to this okay so yeah
this part over here is going to reflect
that we looked at this or Tuesday didn't
really make your subject so let's draw
that in this is just the constructor so
I'm not going to prepare exactly on the
same spot okay there we go
so this is just for the purposes of
illustration usually we reserved dotted
lines dashed lines rather to be
asymptotes that's what's going on t okay
so I've got my components I might
actually label these as well and here is
going to be one of the useful things
where we told you to do these back at
the beginning of to you do I have to do
this just for work right Y goes X it has
an unambiguous equation right it is y
equals x it's y equals x everywhere but
y equals the absolute value of x is
equal to two different things at two
different places okay over here the
absolute value of x is still y equals x
right but I rather negative values for X
the absolute value of x is not 1 equals
x what is it it's wife is negative x
right so back in the day we would have
asked you and said hey really if you
were to do this properly
you ought to label all of your axes
that's sorry not access all of your
branches right
that's a nice neat way to do it but
there was not really much of a reason to
do it apart from making things look neat
but now there is a reason to do it okay
I'm gonna look at these Y values these
ornaments and I'm gonna see what's going
on right I'm gonna start at the middle
of the graph because that's a nice easy
point the ordinates here for both of the
graphs this one of this one the
ordinates here are both 0 do you agree
with that so I'm just going to as the
name suggests I'm just gonna add them so
you're plus 0 is just 0 cool right now
I'm just going to on this graph I'm
going to go to the left so for example
if I go to x equals negative 1 so let's
put that it's feet right at x equals
negative 1 what's the autumn here it's 1
and what's the ordinate down here it's
negative 1 so you add them and that
again use your zero right and you can
keep on going to as many ordinates you
like over on this side they're always
going to be opposite to each other
because the equations tell you they give
the opposite does that make sense so
this actually has a point now right so I
can say yeah all the way over here all
the way off forever and now I'm gonna do
a nice thick line to indicate this is my
actual graph okay if I add together the
ordinates released I just get this well
I get y equals 0 right because you add
these together they exactly cancel out
okay that's for that kind of doing well
now as we move to the right and wet
what's happening figure out the ordinate
again yeah if I ever go over to x equals
1 here the ordinance for the first graph
the first graph
you ought it's just going to be 1 and
the ordinate for this graph is also
going to be 1 so you add them together
giving you 2 whoa where extension to
students I could add right one plus one
equals two you move over again you're
gonna get two plus two equals four
okay so you can see how adding those
ordinates gives you the shape and of
course the shape that are tracing out is
what what is this shape y equals 2x
right because I'm adding y equals x to y
equals x ok all right so that's why you
get this steve Beshear and that's it
that was not romantic right but that was
partly because we started with such an
easy paragraph okay does that make sense
you fine with me